what if you could relive moments of
someone else's life
see what they see touch what they touch
and feel what they feel
all from the comfort of your own home in
cyberpunk 2077
this kind of tech exists and it's called
brain dance
braindance or bd for short is the most
popular form of entertainment in the
cyberpunk universe
although braindance shares some minor
similarities with vr headsets the
technology couldn't be more different
unlike virtual reality bd can engage all
five senses by stimulating your brain in
a variety of ways
this results in a fully immersive
experience that lets you live out
scripted moments as someone else
well the most obvious use for this tech
is porn
it was originally used to rehabilitate
convicted criminals
money now or i will drop your sword
again
invented in 2007 by a uc santa cruz
student named yuriko tsujimoto shout out
to the banana slugs watching
bd was originally called the alternative
reality
process using a netrunner interface
tsujimoto was able to record her
thoughts
feelings and emotions onto a memory chip
and replay them using a modified cyber
deck after tsujimoto finished up her phd
she went to work for the state of
california as a researcher for penal
reform
with the help of a renowned psychologist
named norman lassemer tsujimoto began
developing ways the alternative reality
process
could reprogram and rehabilitate
criminals
using a rudimentary form of bd prisoners
were forced to relive their crimes over
and over again with exaggerated
consequences and
sometimes with incredibly painful
outcomes
[Music]
although many considered it torture it
was effective
however the alternative reality process
faced one major setback that prevented
wider use
most criminals weren't being recorded
when they committed a crime this made it
difficult for a prisoner to receive a
braindance treatment that matched the
offense
to rectify this tsujimoto and lassemer
received funding from both the state of
california and militech to reenact
crimes using
incarcerated volunteers however
recording the crime was only half of it
they also needed to record the
punishment to really hammer home the
whole
rehabilitation side of the experience as
lawless as the cyberpunk universe may be
torturing people to record their pain
was a step too far
or at least it was until a convicted
mass murder by the name of harold d
mcleroy made an interesting offer to
militech militech could record his death
if they generously compensated his
family
militech paid up and put him to death
before the ink on his contract dried
after mick leroy's deal other inmates
proposed similar offers and tsujimoto
began to expand her death and torture
database
thanks to tsujimoto's tech prisoners
were getting rehabilitated at a much
quicker rate than usual
thus freeing up space in prisons as
you'd expect
this method of rehabilitation isn't the
most ethical
many convicts walked away with a litany
of anxiety disorders
with the success of the altered reality
process on inmates tsujimoto and
lassemer formed their own company called
braindance incorporated
shortly after militech partnered with
braindance inc to create military
simulations for training purposes
you know just like that black mirror
episode it can feed you everything that
you did
you will see and smell
and feel it all in 2077 brain dance is
still used for criminal rehabilitation
and military training but it's primarily
used for entertainment
pretty much anyone and everyone
regardless of their socioeconomic
background has
access to a brain dance machine of
course the wealthy can afford top of the
line personal machines but bt arcades
can be found all throughout night city
inside customers can choose from a wide
selection of cartridges to rent and test
out in the arcade itself
in order to experience braindance you
need a bd headset
also known as a wreath and a base
station also known as a feeder
once the user is connected to the unit
it will force the user into a
trance-like state making them
susceptible to other sensory experiences
in the early days of consumer bd most
experiences put the user in the shoes of
someone else doing something
extraordinary
a famous athlete making a game-winning
goal climbing mount everest or reliving
a significant historical event
as the bd industry grew production
companies began creating more in-depth
curated experiences
by 2077 bd covers a wide range of genres
and tastes both
legal and illegal of course there's also
a bunch of weird sex bd cartridges like
sasha devon's three mouths one desire
but there are also horror experiences
like foreign body and popular slice of
life beaties that let you inhabit the
body of a celebrity
kind of like the 1999 comedy being john
malkovich
malkovich there are even some religious
bds that let the user experience jesus's
suffering on the cross first hand which
sounds like a big old yikes to me but
considering people knowingly went to see
passion of the christ in droves i can
see why that might be popular
it's also important to note that
braindance is heavily edited
very rarely is the user given a raw bd
recording to playback because it can be
very difficult to seamlessly plant the
user in someone else's mind
there would be too many irrelevant
thoughts that require context and
memories that are incomprehensible to a
foreign entity in order to clean up a bd
recording you need an editor to pour
over each scene and remove thoughts
emotions and sensations that would be
unrelated to the user
basically if you're making an action bd
you don't want the user to think about
what the actor ate for breakfast
after the bd recording has been edited
the editor may remix the active's
feelings and emotions to give more
weight to certain moments
for instance if the user should be
scared the editor might inject a little
bit more fear into that recording
kind of like how movies attempt to
subconsciously manipulate someone's
feelings with different camera angles
and focal lengths
you see in this world there's two kinds
of people my friend
those with loaded guns
you dig without a certain level of
editing braindance can be very
off-putting and even dangerous
despite the dangers though there is
still a market for more extreme and
authentic bd
that kind of bd goes by the name black
brain dance black brain dance is hard to
come by and usually features recordings
of criminal activity
extreme violence or snuff unlike the
regulated bd you might find an arcade or
a store
black brain dance can be very dangerous
to the user due to the unedited extreme
emotions it can impose
while over-the-counter brain dance isn't
dangerous per se
it can lead to some negative side
effects the obvious one is addiction
many bd setups include a feeder which
gives the user sustenance so they can
stay in a bd transfer as long as
possible
as you can imagine many folks end up
preferring life in a braindance trance
over reality
those who overuse bd are often rendered
numb and emotionless because reality
doesn't quite stir up the same intense
emotions as a well-produced bd
it can also lead to bddid which stands
for braindance dissociative identity
disorder
basically the user spends so much time
in someone else's head that they are
unable to distinguish the self from the
role they take in a bd
this usually happens to those who
routinely return to bds starring their
favorite actors
of course if you saw the first night
city wire you got a sneak peek at how
braindance works in game it will be
interesting to see how much depth
braindance will have when cyberpunk
comes out this november
if you're interested in learning more
about braindance and cyberpunk lore i
highly recommend picking up the
cyberpunk
2077 world book a lot of the info in
this video comes from that very book
but in the meantime for more cyberpunk
lore be sure to check back every
saturday for another video if there's a
topic you'd like to see covered please
let us know in the comments below and
with that
we'll see you next time
you